[Applaudissements]
leur histoire a ému le monde entier
33 mineurs qui ont réussi à remonter à
la surface sains et saufs après 69 jours
coincés sous terre
chaque mineur a été reconduit dans cette
étroite nacelle pendant quinze longues
minutes
tout commence par un éboulement de 700
mille tonnes de roche
les autorités sont sans nouvelles des
mineurs pendant 17 jours puis une sonde
rejoint les hommes vivants et leur
acheminement nourriture vêtements
imessage de leurs proches
au terme d'un sauvetage spectaculaire
ils retrouvent enfin leur famille les
lunettes de soleil indispensable après
avoir passé deux mois dans une noirceur
quasi totale ils ont claqué des poètes a
noté le président du chili fraîchement
élu à l'époque souligné que la richesse
du pays n'était pas le cuivre mais les
travailleurs miniers
dix ans plus tard que sont devenus les
33 mineurs de l'atacama
mario sepulveda 49 ans travaille sur une
ferme à santiago
il avoue se sentir maintenant comme un
héros déchu qu'est ce que le chili nous
a donné depuis le moins que le
gouvernement puisse faire c'est de nous
dédommager dit il
jimmy sanchez avait 19 ans le plus jeune
des 33 lorsqu'il a été rescapé de la
mine avec neuf ans il n'a pas de travail
il affirme même que des employeurs
craignent de l'embauché du à son passé
traumatisant ici gabriel pro radio
canada montréal